[Music]
congratulations to you you were recently
married us yes Justin Makita how is the
how was the wedding it was I mean you
have to say great when it's your wedding
it was amazing
yeah I'm on television I just got
married it was amazing it was a I
thought it was kind of a small affair
apparently it was large I had like 200
people there so my cast members from
Modern Family is really nice you know
it's funny I occasionally come across
pictures I see pictures of Sofia Vergara
your co-star dancing with I've seen it a
few times you know dancing with your now
husband just Justin yeah though I see
those two dancing together a lot yeah
parties but not you dance I'm not a big
dancer and you at my wedding I dance a
little bit but when we go out to like
the Emmy Awards that gold Golden Globes
we've been lucky enough to been invited
to those at the after parties it's
Justin and Sophia you're usually out
there you know cutting up a rug and
she's always doing these these back
bends and it's like her signature move
and she's you know on these evenings
usually dressed in kind of beautiful
gowns and she's a bucks as I don't want
to tell you a very buxom lady there's a
lot going on up top there's a lot
happening so you know I'm always nervous
that something's gonna you know well as
we have what there's one picture here
there's Justin in her and yeah it looks
like anything horrifying could going
anymore and I think on a different
occasion I think something did yeah if
that was actually
that was a look at Justin's face he's
like oh my god boobs yeah yeah it
happened yeah she needs an engineer to
consult holding it all together now I'm
told that you lost your voice recently
yeah I am feeling better than I am thank
you I I it's I'm so embarrassed about
how it happened though I was on set and
I sneezed really hard and I held it in
and I hemorrhaged a vocal cord by
sneezes sneezes never heard of like all
the pressured like went to the vocal
cord of like pop and yeah I I guess
that's what happens when you get old
yeah
but yeah it's it's a thing it's the same
thing that Adele had I don't know I like
she didn't get my sneezing she got it by
singing amazingly but like yeah her
story's a little better now I've gotten
that way too
yeah yeah but yeah so I had to like I
had to read reschedule my my shooting
schedule and I couldn't talk and I was
you couldn't talk at rest you were like
a full week you couldn't talk at all
what happened when you tried to speak
with me like whistle tones and like dogs
would bark in the distance and and I I
went to the grocery store to like you
know I like little things that you
forget about like I need my voice where
like I thought oh I'll cancel all my
plans and I'll just go about my day
doing the things that I need to get done
like going to the grocery store and I I
get to the butcher counter I'd be like I
don't know how to tell this person that
I need some some meat and like so I you
know you hand them a note across the way
which always makes people very nervous
behind it yeah
all of you in a bag give me all your
bill yeah like I'm handing him notes of
saying I've hemorrhaged a vocal cord
I need a pound of ground lamb yeah